every time i told anyone that i was
working on dogs
the first thing they would do was pull
out their smartphone show me a picture
of their dog and tell me all about it
and i'm sitting there as a scientist
going that's that's all the information
that i want is everything you just told
me but but it's not written down
anywhere darwin's arc is our community
science project where we reach out
directly to dog owners and ask them to
participate in our research
what we're increasingly seeing is
science like this project which is a
citizen science project where owners are
more than happy to spend two hours in
front of their computer and answer 117
questions about their dog more than
happy to get that q-tip and do the swab
i reached out to the community of
applied animal behavior experts and
these are people who work in things like
dog training
and i said we're interested in traits
that differ between breeds were easy for
owners to identify
and that people were unlikely to try and
train their dog to do it or train their
dog not to do it basically we want
things that are genetic that are
heritable and they came up with this
fantastic list of questions
does your dog like to play with toys and
is your dog friendly with strangers but
there were also questions like
does your dog circle before he poops
when you have such a huge data set like
this they're looking at descriptions of
thousands of dogs and genome sequences
of almost 2 000 dogs
stuff is going to start to shake out we
found out that behavior in dogs is very
complicated which is not surprising
behavior and everything is very
complicated so we have these behavioral
factors as we scored each dog on and
each factor is actually a bunch of
different survey questions that are all
asking sort of the same thing what we
saw out of these eight factors is that
there were a few of them like whether
your dog was interested in playing with
toys and how trainable your dog was some
of the breeds seemed to be more
different from other dogs on those
particular traits and then there were
others that seemed to have much less of
a signal off of them and one of the ones
that didn't really seem to differ
between breeds much at all the one that
actually scored the lowest out of those
eight factors was one that we'd called
agonistic threshold and that's the kind
of set of questions it's all related to
to how your dog reacts to something it's
surprising or unexpected in their
environment including whether they kind
of react aggressively to it or not there
doesn't really seem to be much there it
seems like that's got a pretty large
environmental component to it
you can't really
predict what an individual dog's
behavior is going to be like accurately
from their breed ancestry alone it's
much too complicated
most of the breeds we think of today
whether it's german shepherds or
labrador retrievers or border collies
traced back only about 160 years to the
victorian era where there was a lot of
really intensive greeting for what dogs
looked like and dog shows were getting
really popular that's a very short
period of time in terms of evolution
but it turns out that dogs were
domesticated from wolves
something like 10 or 20 000 years ago
and so probably at some point people
started
favoring dogs that had behaviors that
were useful to them
eventually you had these kind of working
populations of dogs you have herding
dogs you have livestock guarding dogs
you've got guard dogs
and those have probably been around for
a very long time if you start with a
group of dogs that are bred as a working
population of herding dogs and you
establish a breed from them you will
have a population of dogs that are more
likely to be hurting
type behaviors
one of the reasons that we study dog
genetics at all is that we're interested
in whether understanding how genes shape
behaviors and behavioral disorders in
dogs might actually help us learn
something about things like psychiatric
diseases in people
dogs look a lot different than us
but they actually share the vast
majority of their genes with us and so
it's always really surprising to sort of
break down these species barriers one of
the really cool things that the
researchers also found was they found at
least 11 new spots in dog dna that are
tied to behavior and there's found some
really cool links to human behavior so
they found a new region of dog dna that
seems to be involved with howling and
it's related to respond human dna that's
involved in speech and language they
found a new spot in dog dna that seems
to be related to human social ability
which seems to be related to learning in
humans
two thousand dogs is a pretty remarkable
number to be able to do that with for
context in humans when they study
complex behaviors they often need study
sizes of hundreds of thousands and even
millions of people i encourage everybody
to go sign up for darwin's arc because
the more dogs the better at this point
in time somebody asked me once how many
dogs i wanted and i said well you know
ideally all of them would be great
while this study is certainly
surprising and bound to be controversial
even the authors admit you know this is
just the beginning and potentially with
larger sample sizes they may start to
see correlations that they're not seeing
now the more genetic information the
more of a foothold other scientists are
going to have for
teasing out these genes that are
responsible for behavior or potentially
psychological issues or behavioral
issues and things like that both in dogs
and in people
well it's not really a secret anymore
because i keep telling everybody but but
my dirty secret as a dog genetics person
was that i
have never actually owned a dog i own
three cats they are fantastic
and i would love to have a cat genetics
project one day